[Musique]
bienvenue à saint-etienne où
l'association sétif ou de réunions à
représenter notre île lors de la 5e
édition du tournoi national en dix
supporters
un tournoi qui favorise le vivre
ensemble à travers le foot
heureuse d'être en métropole cette
équipe est composée de dix joueurs
porteurs de handicap et le trois
accompagnateurs dont fait partie david
waro mal sur sportif de l'association
cécifoot des damien tu mets ça aux bleus
je sais ça fait la quatrième année que
nous mettre ce projet là en place c'est
important parce que ce sont des jeunes
qui sont à bannir la pratique sportive
des bêtes à ces jeunes de de faire du
sport de refaire du sport d'être
valorisés en fait cela pratique donc
développé aussi une estime de soi enfin
l'idée c'est ça les objectifs sont
clairs changer le regard des jeunes
envers eux-mêmes mais aussi des
considéré avant tout comme des sportifs
à part entière montrer qu'ils sont
autrement capables
ce tournoi est donc un excellent moyen
d'exposer leur talent mais aussi de
faire tomber les barrières
[Musique]
et permettent à moins trouvé doté de
personnes qui m'ont jamais dit je trouve
que c'est bon parce que c'est un échange
normal à bitche avec tout le monde c'est
le paradise on est libre et fière un
beau projet donc qui nécessite une
logistique soutenu par des partenariats
financiers
ce sont des initiatives accompagné par
le département de la réunion qui est
très sensible à ces actions
d'intégration sociale ce séjour à
caractère sportif et culturel était
organisée par notre association pour à
paunat le département de la réunion qui
vers company 2 sur 10 sur ce projet par
intermedia de madame dindar et ensuite
on a aussi un ths territoires ruraux
jeunesse et sport qui nous accompagnent
en fait sur ce projet qui permet en fait
de nous accueillir à saint-etienne et
l'association des réunionnais de
saint-etienne
effectivement il ya de l'intérêt il ya
il y à travers ces aides il ya vraiment
un soutien un soutien qui pourtant
prendre dé soutien essentiel pour les
associations qui peuvent plus facilement
accompagner et aider les jeunes porteurs
de handicap à trouver une place dans la
société
c'est pas seulement avoir une volonté
faut passer par des actes et ce projet
là justement c'est une mise en pratique
des actes de vol à les intégrer les
considérer comme des sportifs et non des
personnes handicapées est justement
permettre à ces jeunes là de vivre une
belle aventure humaine et sportive aussi
[Musique]
et l' aventure sportive a été bien
présente pendant deux jours une
vingtaine d'équipés sont confrontés lors
du tournoi andy supporters au stade de
l'etivallière les équipes qui mêle des
personnes porteuses de handicap et des
valides
une compétition de valeur car elles
véhiculent des valeurs humaines pour
l'association sont comme nous ils
n'arrivent à jouer il arrive à être
solide et il arriva à échanger à
communiquer il n'y a plus de barrières
c'est extraordinaire de vivre cette
expérience là et je pense que nous tous
on le ressent la rave est ce tournoi
[Musique]
des rencontres et des échanges qui mène
à leur épanouissement personnel et à la
construction d'une identité heureuse
pour jean jimmy michael et yann cet
événement leur permet aussi de
représenter la réunion fait partie des
championnats de france ça c'était à
toulouse
mais là quand vous allez à saint-etienne
comptant la réunion leur mamie et ça et
tenir ça comme une fierté pour
représenter la région et mon degré si
possible avancée pour dire qu'il me
demandait un complice poursuivre que mes
oies qui minait les compétences des
matériels causés le match pour gagner là
pour
[Musique]
les jeunes qui sont heureux de
s'exprimer sur le terrain et qui partage
leurs valeurs aussi en dehors du terrain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe de la réunion finira septième
de sa poule ils reviendront avec une
coupe des souvenirs plein la tête mais
leur plus grande victoire reste de
changer les regards les avis du handicap
et d'avoir ce sentiment d'être
considérés comme n'importe quel sportif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]